see what it was
okay so we know on showmanuchi
right
uh he's going to one not start
out there he starts out there
go I'm gonna move
it doesn't make sense
strikes are closer to range strives are
closer to the range than katate because
his Target is closer than Kentucky you
see he's in range okay
and then we know on show manucci that I
address it as it's going up
I never address it on its way down I
don't care what deflection angle you're
doing
you catch it on its way up
right
okay so on omote go I step with the lead
foot
we're going to do it
I step with the back foot you gotta not
uh worry about me you got to keep your
attack going all right
there he goes who I stepped with the
outside foot now he pressured whoa too
much still
too much
here he goes too much
and when I feel that you might move out
of the way
the same orientation
okay so catch it and you don't do that
just you're gonna you want to hit me
oh
slap
so I made contact
okay who's spot two do you hear it no
it's it's yield
[Music]
and in that sense it's no different than
this one that I was eating kept in a Yin
phase
too much time
difference
okay what's key is that okay actually
throws the strike is not posting at the
top not having their hand up okay
all right it's it looks much easier but
I'll show you where there's some
differences okay so on the first one my
hand should be the same
I'm not going to be on the outside
because that hand's gonna hit
and I want the hand I don't want to
deflect it okay if you wanted to deflect
it sure Let It Go by
but in this technique I the elbow is
what I'm going for so the elbow I can't
hear
boom okay now when he comes down I don't
want to grab his arm
that arm's coming that arm that elbows
that wrist is flying you're not going to
catch it from going behind it
and I don't need to so warm I'll just on
the elbow
just on the elbow
you see and it's here is where if you
wanted to
crutches
if you wanted to okay
pay attention and again you can move
around
I don't need that
I don't need his
arm my arms are gonna continue to roll
his elbow
to the up position
his elbows down
so there's no way you can stay here do
you see
but as you come around
his arms coming down
you keep rolling it at the elbow
[Music]
okay so uh
my task is this
okay and I want to show you the the hard
Parts okay
he lets it by him do you see
here
I'm not going fast
let's let it buy her again okay
there's that jam
did you feel that okay
same thing
[Music]
cool a jam again
is that your Technique
this is on the side you think and she's
trying to pull it
foreign
so
again if I'm on the side it's gonna go
by me
there's no way
and if I go
and connect on the top
I had to go on the side and it's gonna
keep going
right he didn't finish his step
and now we're moving away from each
other is he
so I have to come off
and then this becomes the axis of
rotation
he comes down
oh
[Music]
I'm never on the side though
he's I'm just healing
to get flowy pauses at the top easy
peasy
right by the guy striking
not easy
unless you can do it then he goes down
easy peasy okay
like